معي خالد محجوب اللواء ومدير اداره
التوجيه المعنوي في القوات المسلحه
العربيه الليبيه حدث اللواء اهلا بك ماذا
تعني عندما تقول هناك سيناريوهات سيئه واا
يعني وجهت انذار
انذار حقيقي اذا ما كانت هذه يعني حول هذه
السيناريوهات
القائد العام المشير خليفه
مساء امس او ظهيره الامس في الكلمه كانت
واضحه الرساله وقويه همم ان ما يحدث الان
لا يمكن السكوت عنه هناك تواصل مع كل
المناطق في ليبيا تعلن عن رفضها واستياءها
باستمرار هذا الوضع وايضا استعدادها
للتعاون والتعامل مع الموقف همم بما
يقتضيه همم في ظل همم ما تحدث عنه همم
القائد العام بان القوات المسلحه دائما
للشعب وداعمه للحراك الوطنيه
التي الان بدات بالفعل طلاب لما همم يعني
همم جموحها وتسعه لان تنطلق في عام الوطني
بكل تاكيد هام جدا في هذه المرحله
الليبيينهم همم مساله تدوير الازمه والح
وماتت التي تاتي همم كجرعات علاج مؤقت في
الحقيقه كانت تزيد الازامات سوءا عليه
سواء في معيشته ووصلت حتى الى انتهاء
سيادته وهو ما اصبح يعبر عنه المواطن
الا ماذا ما هي الخيارات امام الجيش
الاوراق ولكن بكل تاكيد هناك التواصل قلت
لك مع القوه الوطنيه وكل المناطق
بتاثيراتها الاجتماعيه
وايضا تاثيراتها همم حتى الاداريه فيما لو
استمر الوضع كما هو عليه خصوصا بعد مجموعه
من التصرفات التي همم يعني يتبعها المواطن
همم من الحكومه التي همم الان همم تتواجد
في طرابلس ويعتبر الان طلب بعض المناطق
ايضا حتى محتله
والفقي حتى ل همم ليس فقط للشرعيه ولكن
فقط للسيادتها بمطلق الكلمه
التي منها القوات المسلحه باعتبارها اكثر
من ثلاثه ارباع البلد بالتاكيد همم لن
يطول السكوت وايضا المناطق التي ترزختها
الخيارات عسكريه الخيارات حضره اللواء
امامكم كاريه امسيه شو يعني لن يطول
السكوت ماذا ستفعللون
مع هذا الانذار وهذا الخيار وعندما تتبدل
الاحوال لدينا اوراقا التي سنكشف عنها ان
شاء الله عندما تتحدث عن سيناريوات سيئه
ماذا اسوء بالنسبه لليبيا من الوضع الحالي
يعني الدوله بهذا الشكل اذا باستمر كما هو
على ايه سنفقد حتى يعني ستصبح الدوله
مدانه ليصدق نقد ستفقد قدراتها على يعني
اصبح دوله فاشله للاسف يعني بهذه الاداره
بهذا الشكل الذي يستمر فيه نزف ثروات
البلد يستمر فيه فقدان سيادتها يستمر فيه
انتهان المواطن كل ما يحصل الان وجود
القوات الاجنبيه وغيرها كل هذه الامور
الحقيقه همم المواطن لم يعد يرى بامكان ان
يستمر في السقوط عليها وبالتالي همم اذا
ما وصل الحال الى قوه المواطن بهذا الشكل
والتفكر ليبيا حتى قدرتها الماليه رغم
انها الدوله الدوله ثروات
هل التقسيم او التفتت رائحه الخيارات
السيئه
وبين التقسيم نحن كثوره الكرامه ثوره
واحده
ليس لها علاقه بهذه همم
الترهات التي يدعيها البعض نحن ابدا لن
نكون قاسم في اي تقسيم في ليبيا بالعكس
نحن من حافظ على همم يعني الكيان الليبي
نحن من نسى الى ان لم ليبيا نحن من نسى
الى ان تكون ليبيا واحده لا يمكن ان تقبل
القسمه ابدا وبالتالي همم هذا همم شيء لا
يمكن التفكير فيها هناك دعايه ظهرت حاول
البعض تشويه بها القياده العامه وان هناك
رغبه في ذلك من اجل السلطه وهذا غير حقيقي
يعني تم رد ذلك عليهم بقوه بالامس عندما
تم تفنيد كل هذه الشائعات الكبيره
المعنوي في القوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه شكرا لك